Exporting and importing assets within the FBX pipeline in
the engine can be a simple task with just the right settings.
So the settings we're looking for in your Maya exporting is when
after you've selected the FBX format, you want to make sure there are certain things that are
checked on. In this case, if you know, the smooth mesh is disabled
and the smoothing groups are enabled. Now if you have an animation to include,
you want to go ahead and checkmark that there. Do not use the bake animation.
That is when you're going to use the limbic format within Maya
to do that. Now on 3ds max exporting, it's basically the
same. So we don't need to go over those settings. Now if you are interested
in Blender exporting, one, there is a Send to UE plugin
that is available through that YouTube and a link that is attached to that.
That goes over about installing and using that. Again, we won't be covering that today
because that is outside the scope of today's purpose. Now we do export
from Blender and we're going to show you that. This is the Export FBX
and you're going to have to fix the transforms. Now there's also this thing called
Add Leavebones. You want to make sure that is checked off as
Unreal will see that as separate elements. So you actually wind up bringing in multiple
characters and that's not what you're going to want. Now smoothing groups doesn't exist
like it does in other DCC programs. So you're going to make sure you have
the auto smooth, edge split, and apply modifiers checked before exporting
from Blender, as well as unchecked baked animation.